Đó là đoàn thương mại và công nghiệp Vietnam, có chỉ chỉ đến thương nhân đồng mối sâu dịch và đồng mối luôn phía sức hậu gạo.
Theo hợp đồng tập trung, lãnh tạo xa sàng sàng gia nhập thị trường rất lớn, đối với các thương nhân mới cũng như các suy nghiệp nhỏ vào vừa.
Thế thư chỉ có lãi để bộ công thương lợi trọng thương nhân đồng mối, hoặc phân bầu chỉ tiêu ý thác xuất hậu,
dựa chủ ý ổ vào thành tý xuất hậu trong 2 năm cần nhất và niềm tính nhạc.
Bộn cũng vụ thuộc và sản lượng xuất hậu của hướn, điều này vô hình chung tạo nên một vòng trọng khác kiến,
xuất nghiệp muốn có chỉ tiêu xuất hậu lớn thì phải có thành tích.
Nhưng đẹt có thành tý xuất hậu sản cơ thể thị trường xác dịch đập trung,
thông qua bản viên nhớ thỏa thuận thương mại, xuất nghiệp lại bắt bộ phía đủ chỉ định làm đồng mối tử trước.
Hậu qua là tất thương nhân mới hậu xuất nghiệp nhỏ vào vừa, dụ đa vấn đề đủ đu kiện tình xanh
và chủ đọc liên kết chủ ý sản xuất biển bướng,
và miệng loại khỏi tương hội cảnh trình xong phản,
quy lợi xuất khẩu tất cả thì trường trong biển giảy bị thông tóm,
bởi một nhóm nhỏ xuất nghiệp sử hữu thị phần lịch sử.
Đây tạo mua trường cảnh trình của mình đàn hơn,
Visi CIA gian nghiệp bộ xuống cơ trế phân bộ riêng,
có thể tương khoảng 1,5% lượng gạo trong các hậu đồng tập trung,
để đấu thậu công khai,
khoảng phân bộ riêng cho nhóm thương nhân mới,
xuất nghiệp vừa và nhỏ đã xây dự trụ lên kết sản xuất và báo tiêu sản phẩm.
Tình mình đàn.